the 911 turbo made its debut at the
Paris Motor Show in 1974 it started out
with a 260 horsepower engine but in 1977
the car got a power boost thanks to its
new enter cooling system the 3.3 liter
motor could generate 300 horsepower
christophe says the 911 turbo is more
than just a car it's the stuff of legend
in the 1970's and 80's there was no
getting away from it whether you were a
yuppie or a technical freak a grandma or
a kid this car polarized people kristov
adds they either loved it or hated it
coveted or vilified it but it certainly
didn't leave them cold as the world's
first turbocharged series production
supercar the Porsche 911 Turbo combined
power with luxury
originally designed as a race car some
last-minute changes to the regulations
robbed it of its chances on the track
but not to be daunted Porsche switched
gears and turned the vehicle into a
luxury sports car though it retained one
race car characteristic its turbo lag
crystal says rally driver vault Aurora
once described it this way you step on
the gas and for a few seconds nothing
happens then suddenly it feels like
you've been rear-ended Christophe says
that's true and provides a demonstration
whoo-hoo this baby really flies he says
it's enough to strike fear into the
hearts of the Italians at Lamborghini
and Ferrari when it made its debut the
911 Turbo cost close to 66,000 darhk's
20,000 more than the priciest 911
Carrera still thanks to its stunning
looks and superior performance by 1989
over 21,000 of the original turbo models
had been sold 0 to 100 kilometres an
hour and 5.5 seconds and a top speed of
260 kilometers an hour
that's what Christophe calls performance
but he warns inexperienced drivers to
beware if they hit the gas at the wrong
moment and then the turbocharger kicks
in the rear end could spin out of curves
even Porsche knew the 911 turbo was hard
to handle it's a real sports car and
requires concentration to drive this
commercial states but it rewards you
with a high level of safety and driving
pleasure
those who equate driving pleasure with
great acceleration and power will find
few cars to match the original 911 turbo
even today what a beast christoph says
noting that the 911 turbos trademark
rear spoilers are hard to overlook when
the car was introduced many owners of
regular 911s had these whale tails added
to their vehicles christophe says this
didn't escape the attention of the
designers at Porsche and they eventually
offered this turbo look for regular 911
complete with tail fin fender extensions
and fatter Fuchs wheels Krista finds
that all a bit embarrassing though
the design of the 911 turbo turned out
to be a hit thought was born of
necessity the wing extensions are from
the Carrera 3.0 RS with slight
modifications and a porsche designer
gave the body of final going-over
outside of regular work hours due to the
firm's limited budget his reward was a
bottle of whiskey the interior
incorporated all of the optional extras
Porsche had to offer
however the huge intercooler for the 3.3
liter engine only arrived at the end of
1977
the original 911 turbo wasn't lacking
for anything Christophe says but the 3.3
liter model came with even more extras
power windows power seats power sunroof
but such luxury didn't come cheap in
1974 the turbo cost over 65 thousand
euros a third more than the most
powerful naturally aspirated Porsche of
the day the Carrera 2.7 even though it's
incredibly powerful Christophe says the
turbo is more of a Gran Turismo than
race car and that sports cars
enthusiasts prefer naturally aspirated
portions that's because the turbo only
gets to flex its impressive muscle on
straightaways every naturally aspirated
911 delivers more precise and smooth
handling when taking curves still the
turbo helped Porsche attract a new type
of customer christophe says the 911
turbo was the first and most successful
turbocharged supercar its arrival put
Porsche on a par with Italian supercar
makers like Lamborghini and Ferrari
compared to other supercars Christoph
believes that turbo strikes the right
balance between sportiness and
practicality between the racetrack and
the supermarket for that reason he feels
the 911 turbo is truly a milestone in
automotive history and a legendary car
model to boot little wonder as three
decades after it was introduced that
turbocharged 911 still packs a real
punch
you